only on CBS this morning we like when we  can say that we are revealing the  winners of the Department of Interior  share the experience photo confiscating  the gorgeous stuff more than 15,000  photos the federal lands were submitted  the grand prize winner drumroll please  is this camouflaging frog is taken by  Craig McIntyre at a National Wildlife  Refuge in Texas this photo will be  featured on the annual national parks  and federal recreational land pass you  can see more of the incredible photos on  a CBS this morning Instagram feed well  need certainly does blend right in yes  camouflage does it looks like we're a  six yes he does